you know what chris i want to ask you
before we let you go
uh basketball fans know that our first
black president was barack obama our
second black president is glenn doc
rivers
uh
who got uh dismissed by the clippers
we're all in mourning over it so
uh was it justified did you see this one
coming i mean this was like a a pretty
big stunner chris
no i didn't see it coming the reason i
didn't see it coming because you know
the day after the game you know the
clippers front you know uh front office
brass told me that doc rivers was safe
and so i i wrote that
and i have no problem you know the
bulging that now um but
i was um yeah i was i was taken back
just by you know what i was told you
know after the game now obviously
things can change and that's that's the
way the world is things change from then
to to there and so obviously some things
went on
in between time to get to the point
where we are now where doc rivers uh is
without a team
and so uh but i think doc did a good job
look you know paul george and kawhi
leonard they have one year left under
contract and i think it would have been
nice to let you know doc
you know
go that year see what he can do with
that year hey look i mean just think
about the like i said this was an
unconventional season and you know how
mantra harold he was out for a little
like a month during the restart patrick
bradley took time away lou williams like
they were just in [ __ ] and they were one
of the teams that voted not to continue
playing when it was on that little
hiatus during this restart so the team
wasn't exactly focused and it wasn't
because of doc rivers and so i i just
don't think he had a real solid chance
solid chance of a year to put his
imprint on that team and yeah you know
interesting to see where they go from
here
no that's a good point um i think will
probably happen between what the what
your sources told you and them letting
them go is steve ballmer seeing the
lakers beat the nuggets and go back to
the finals when he felt like that was
probably supposed to be them and
somebody had to be the fall guy before
we let you go man on doc rivers uh saw
the report today
that he is um
visiting with philadelphia or interview
oh did we lose chris
oh he said okay we saw a report that uh
that he's supposed to be interviewing
with philadelphia we thought they were
gonna hire mike d'antoni what do you
know about his chances to land in philly
well i'll say this right now it's um i
don't know if he's met right now with
him but i'll say this when you looking
at personnel
i think
doc rivers scheme and the way he coaches
i think he fits philadelphia more so
than mike d'antoni and so i think right
now you look at it i mean god the guy
was fine was it was it yesterday was let
go yesterday
um
already over there in philly so this guy
he's going to have
he's going to have no shortage of
options if he wants to get back in the
coaches right away and um you know some
pretty some nice jobs out there
philadelphia new orleans and indiana but
i think for his i think philadelphia is
smart and if they can pull it together
i think doc rivers is the right guy for
that job i just don't see the the
three-point uh three-point or or dump
thing working uh what dan antonio likes
to implement i just don't think that's
working with ben simmons and joel and b